hello my name is paulie nierkov i'm a 3r
coordinator
at the university of zurich and my
research
interest lies in the field of refining
pain management
and pain assessment in laboratory mice
and this is what i'm going to talk about
today i'm going to do that
in a very simple and um basic way and if
you are
an expert for veterinary analgesia or
something might be a little basic
to you but i think because we have a lot
of potential
in refining pain treatment of
these very small laboratory species i
think it makes sense to start
at the very beginning and makes sense
because
unfortunately there are many reports and
reviews
that state and under use of analgesia
in small animal treatment not just
in laboratory animal medicine but also
in small pet
animal practice obviously you will find
many comments of experts like for
example paul flacknell
who we report and underuse of energy
analgesics in the
field of mouse treatment
and additionally you will find
systematic reviews and this is just one
example
by larry caboni for example you find
systematic reviews that show that energy
is
either not used regularly in small
animals
or it is underreported here for example
a systematic review
of articles that report of
pain for procedures and you see we do
have a reporting of energies here of
about 10
to at max 65 70 percent
and from my experience performing
systematic reviews on
analgesia insults certain procedures and
models i can tell you that i assume
that 60 to 70 is really on the good side
um in many many fields energizia
reporting it's very bad
and that's a problem because we do not
know what is the status quo
in analgesia used in small rodents
and we do not know um also
how good the data is that has been um
achieved or that has been yielded with
this kind of studies because
we know that pain and energies here has
a huge impact on
experimental readout and therefore this
is actually information you should know
when you want to assess or evaluate a
scientific
study so
this is why i'm going to talk about
basic refinements or simple refinements
and pain management
i like to highlight here that pain
management is of course
no refinement right pain management is a
must it's a scientifical and ethical
must
but of course there are easy ways to
find a better
pain management protocols or to refine
existing pain management protocols
and i'm going to do that today in seven
steps so these are
my seven steps either people might have
another approach
but i think one of the most important
step is to
accept that there is no gold standard
different individuals
may react differently towards drug
treatment this might be due
to different strains and lines the age
the sex of an animal and also of course
the health status which has a huge
impact
and therefore we have to acknowledge
that there is no one-size-fits-all gold
approach toward
analgesia towards pain treatment and
therefore
we have to treat every individual animal
as a patient as a tiny patient
but as a patient which we would do also
with larger animals and with humans of
course
and there are different ways to approach
these one is maybe the platter approach
from veterinary medicine
um but you will find other structured
way to approach this the important thing
is
that you do approach it and really try
to
improve and not just use what you have
always used because that might
already be outdated by now
so step number two very important what
can be expected
so what kind of pain do you expect how
painful
is your disease how painful is your
procedure
is this inflammatory neuropathic or
neuropathic pain
is this severe pain or not how long is
it lasting how is the course of the pain
all these things you have to know to
decide on an analgesic substance
and additionally of course as i said
before there are certain characteristics
of the patient
that might affect how a drug is acting
so
line age sex health status and so on and
so on
and because we are talking about animal
experimentation
you also should find an analgesia that
has
no side effects on your readout or
acceptable and controllable side effects
that is not trivial but it's super
important
we have some challenges first of all
there's not a lot of published studies
on that
um that really publish clinical relevant
literature so
we are missing pk studies for mice very
often
we might not know what is the duration
of clinical relevant action what is the
clinical relevant effective dose of a
certain drug
we of course have pk studies
pharmacokinetic studies right
but very often with very exotic dosages
or very exotic
administration roots still not that
useful for the standard use
same is maybe true for p these that is
pharmacodynamics
and also in the past we had the problem
that we were missing sensitive pain
indicators for mice
um this is changing at the moment
and therefore do not rely on what you
did
all the time right i checked the recent
publication
check expert recommendations there are a
lot of
revisions of recommendations at the
moment um
if you don't find that you might have to
do pilot experiments but you will find a
lot of very
useful literature maybe even a
publication on you
specific model not only describing how
to assess pain but also how to treat it
maybe
and there are also these expert
informations of different societies that
can be very useful
in deciding on all these important
things that you need to know
when you want to plan an analgesia
protocol
you know what can be expected you know
which energy
substance can be used because this
steers it somehow right i'm not going
into detail
and describe different substance classes
here
um of course it makes a huge difference
which
type of pain you have and you will
decide on very different
pain substances if you have more severe
or less severe pain
um but to give you a little bit of an
example i
choose branophine because it's very
often used and i
and i personally work a lot with it and
so to describe some of the challenges
and the
preconditions that we have to consider
starting with paprika um it has a
quite strong or relatively strong energy
easier
which is pro so it's an opioid centrally
acting
of course um i wouldn't use brenopin as
a single analgesia with very strong
pain because it's just not potent enough
for that
um but for many many pain states it's
very useful
it has a quite lasting effect of let us
say eight hours which is nice because
most opioids
act very short and you can apply it in
very different ways
it has some side effects because it's an
opioid observation and some behavioral
side effects i will go into detail
in a few minutes you might have a slight
immunomodulation
but actually that's a pro pro right
because
um with most opioids you will have quite
some
immune modulation so that's already nice
um we know relatively good
what you have to inject for example
and for have enough to have an effective
analgesia with blueprint but it's still
quite a range right it's 0.05 to zero
in in mice i wouldn't go below 0.05 i
don't think that is
enough in mice
but we know but this is quite okay
already we
have huge ranges of dosages for other
analgesics
so buprenorphine is one of the best
known analgesic substances in mice or
the best described one
for others we are not that safe we are
not that secure we do not know
what actually is the best dose and you
might
know that there is a discussion on
copper caprophain for example
at the moment that the dosage
recommendations are really different or
are differing a lot
between different um authors so
that's already a plus again for
breathing
um you have as i said certain side
effects that are typical
for this drug and this is something you
have to know and you should know this
also for other drugs if you use them and
i just bought here some right
um this is for example photoprinting a
reduction
of food intake and therefore maybe a
reduction in body weight
which could be related to constipation
or nausea you know mice cannot vomit
so what they show is that that will not
eat anymore or
they will show pickle behavior which is
something we know from rats a lot
so eating of non-eatable substances can
be really life-threatening
in red in mice not that much
but can be observed also and then we
have side effects like
you see it here we have here a
normal mouse during the day so naive
uh sleeping most of the time and then
during the night it's red
it's active most of the time and if you
inject time jessica three times during
24 hours for example it looks like this
so a lot of
activity we call it hyper locomotion
and if you have a very high dose here
for example a sustained release
formulation you might have even more
activity that could be harmless but it
could be a problem if you
are into behavior or circadian rhythm
and you cannot wait long enough
after your surgery for your assessment
other typical side effects are these
strobe tails or these tiptoe gate
like hyperlocal motion something that i
would expect
quite normal wouldn't worry me too much
but um keep in mind
other side effects that could be a
warning sign like sedation
because that should not happen actually
in most mouth strains
so these are things you have to know if
you want to use an energetic
um but some of these side effects might
be
totally acceptable but if you have now
decided on a
substance i would highly recommend not
to decide just on
one sometimes it's the only way to go
but if you can use a multimodal approach
i would do that that would be the
approach you would choose in a larger
animal that would be the approach you
would choose in a human
multimodal approaches that means you
might use different classes of
analgesics and
maybe even different sides of
administration and the principle behind
this
is to have complementary
pharmacokinetics
um and also complementary mechanisms of
actions
and ideally that would result in a
synergistic effect and it has
um the result of a maximization of
effects so more pain or better pain
relief or longer pain relief and a
minimization of side effects
because you might need lower
dosages of the single substances for
this
and there are different ways to achieve
a multimodal
protocol and one important is of course
the combination of systemic
drugs and local anesthetics
unfortunately also
very rarely used in small
rodents at the moment but it really has
an advantage
because it really reduces the need for
systemic pain relief
a lot
step number five the administration
route
so um the most easiest way
or the easiest way is always to go
orally right
so just offer something and the animal
ingested
voluntary and that would mean no stress
for you
and no stress for the animals if you
don't use garbage that would be not a
voluntary
all intake then of course but you have
to keep in mind if you go orally
there are some issues you have to
calculate and one could be
it might not be completely controllable
but that totally depends
on how you do it we will talk about that
later
but you might have problems with
solubility compatibility
and very often bioavailability so
bioavailability is
lower in oral intake very often and you
have to calculate that of course
to have still a pain relief if you go
systemic
that is more controllable of course
depending on the
method it goes of course with restraint
and injection which could be stressful
but at least you have um
a safe intake so whatever you want to do
you have to balance right if you have
severe pain
you will for sure not go orally only
right you probably
need a systemic approach you have to
inject something
but if you have more mild pain you have
to balance the stress of the restraint
and the injection against the secure
pain relief and maybe you come to the
conclusion that in some cases
and voluntary oil intake is fine and
is something that can really refine your
animal
experiment and i will give you some
examples of this
in a few minutes when should you
applique yeah as
early as possible so we would call that
pre-emptive or preventive analgesia
so treat before any kind of pain occurs
and then how often do you need to
applicate again that has something to do
with the route and with the substance um
keep in mind a very frequent application
can lead to stress and maybe induce even
pain in the animal if you to strain and
freshly operate the animal
therefore some opioids might not be very
useful because
they are only acting less than an hour
or a few hours
otherwise like buprenorphine might be
okay to inject because they
act right hours if you have a
nonsteroidal and inflammatory drug
you might have the luxury to inject only
every 12 hours because they
are very often longer acting
and here is an example as i said
brentwood
again we would normally target
those of 0.5 nanogram per milliliter in
the serum
to expect a clinically relevant
concentration in the organism what you
see here is the injection of
jessica suboperation once in green or
maybe
two times in blue and then you see serum
concentration and what you see
is well after four to six hours it might
be okay
but after eight hours we already are
quite
below the serum target concentration
therefore we would expect that
buprenorphine
acts around 8 hours but not longer
therefore you have to inject frequently
maybe even
more often than eight hours that's of
course not
um ideal i will
come to this later um
you could now argue well well this is in
centrally acting
opioids so am i really interested in the
serum concentration well i can of course
also offer you the brain concentration
of buprenorphine
that's another study from our lab
what you see here is a comparison of a
depot formulation of puprinophene and a
normal non-retarded formulation
dengesik um and you see yes
after 12 hours we still have in both
formulations
quite high some so concentrations in
this case not
serum but in the brain um that should
um hint towards effectiveness of this
drug
but of course you cannot rely just on
the concentration and a certain
tissue so this is so what you see here
now is an
energy zoom metric test and you saw here
12 hours and here again you see 12 hours
and you see that in an energy energy
geometric test
we do not see any more a significant
difference
between the um jessic
and the control group which is in this
case um just um
nasal so saline injected animals so
we cannot be sure that after that this
kind of
brain concentration really indicates a
clinically relevant and effective dose
so we still stick to the eight hours
until proven or otherwise so i think
you are also quite okay with eight hours
that's probably very safe guess
um so but how to refine that
right i already mentioned sustain
release and the performance
because this is of course a very nice
approach
to get rid of these frequent
applications
administrations right and also a
continuous and stress-free or
stress-reduced administration
would be very nice this can be
done with osmotic pumps
but that's an invasive approach of
course
solvent injectable systems containing
the drugs
that might be a way to go and what i
mean are sustained release formulations
or the poor formulation or [ __ ]
formulation
um which so you inject once and then you
might have an analgesia for two to three
days
maybe one day depends on the formulation
if you are from the u.s and you're
watching this talk from the us
you are lucky because you can buy these
kind of sustained release formulations
if you are from anywhere else in the
world you probably cannot
which is really a pity because this is a
very very
good refinement and a very important
refinement approach
um but you saw and in my slides before
it is possible
to get the pro formulations of
if you do them or if you if you prepare
them yourselves
um and we did this in our studies in the
past
and we could do it because we have a
collaborator who's a
who has a lot of expert
expertise and also the equipment that is
needed
so if you have that in your organization
in your lab
that's fine you might do it by yourself
if not you probably have to rely
on other approaches and a very typical
approach
is to use so-called uncontrolled
voluntary intake protocols
these here are single drinking events of
mice during the day
and doing the dark and this already
shows us the problem this might be
true for drinking water it's probably
very comparable to food pellets
might be even true for medigel or other
substances that you might mix
with energies here and that is that
animals just
while they do ingest water for example
very frequently and very often during
the dark waste
during the bright phase this is very
infrequent so this is something you
cannot rely on
when there is substantial pain therefore
this is
not to be recommended when there is more
than mild pain
so when you want to use this you
probably have to inject
at least during the day time
there are alternatives to this
uncontrolled intake
they have some advantages and some
disadvantages
but i like to show them to you because i
think they are super useful
for especially for mild pain and maybe
as an add-on
to a systemic um approach
for a kind of multi-modal approach maybe
um
and these are control voluntary intake
protocols
and this here for example is an approach
where you just drop
the substance mixed with in this case
it's
honey directly into the mouth of an
animal
um this is an anti-parasitic drug in
this case but you can of course do that
also with an energetic
of course this still needs a little bit
of restraint but you can do better
and um this is another example
so control voluntary intake wire jelly
so a sterile jelly
mixed with a substance that you want to
have the animal ingest
that is like the one before totally
controllable
because you see that it there was an
intake at a certain time
and you see if it was a complete or
maybe just a partial intake and then you
could still
react and give for example a rescue
energies here
if needed so this one this protocol here
you find the video in a protocol
exchange server
this video shows an intake completely
without any interaction this could be
also medi-gel
this could be also nutella or peanut
butter or whatever the animals like to
eat
this here is an example from
the epsl shortly
of course a red mouse
this is a red that has been trained just
something that is mixed with something
that the red really likes
what you see here is really a controlled
intake so you know
how much went into the animal at a
certain time point you can be sure
everything is in
you saw it's no stress for the people
involved is no stress for the animal
it might be even rewarding for the
animal because
we have to be honest they are quite
bored with their normal food so if they
get
something additional it's like
a reward something that could be even
considered to be a refinement so
if your substance administration works
like this
of course that's perfect now you could
say well
this is a rat right we are talking here
about mice and rats are so easy
that you can train them they get tame
and so on and so on
that's not possible with a mouse well i
can tell you well it is it's impossible
with up like six miles right
so that's here a voluntary intake
protocol
based on condensed milk in a black six
the animals are trained for three days
so meaning
three three training sessions this is
already day three
it works because this is a pipette right
this works because um
contents make is something they just
favor so
if you find something that fits with
your
substance this is a very nice approach a
very nice refinement approach to get
something into an animal
without having restrained stress and so
on
okay step number six nearly
finished now um i think these
administration protocols
have a huge potential for refinement and
you should
think about what you can do but what at
least has
the same potential for refinement at the
moment i think are
non-pharmalogical measures also because
there's so many things you can do
to make it easier to make it less
burdensome for the animal
one could be for example using less
invasive techniques and so on
i really like to highlight a septic
technique
also which is also super important for
rodent surgery
to get rid of any kind of
subclinical infections
and so on and so on or any kind of of um
problems during recovery i also highly
recommend warming and i do not mean just
warming during surgery but also after
surgery
um also for quite some time so why not
if you have a warming cabinet warm your
animals for 24 hours after recover
after surgery in our experience in very
severe models this can reduce mortality
but also in less severe models it can
really reduce the time
to recovery to full recovery use
soft food use fluid therapy whenever
possible
and there is really no need to feed an
animal that an event cranial to me with
normal
pellets right you can use high caloric
recovery food also for other models of
course
and this can really make it easier for
the animal
use of bedding use more national
building material because
this helps them to keep warm i use a
social and familiar environment that
means
get them back to their group as soon as
possible
and use gentle handling techniques
cupping or tunnel handling
should anyhow be used if you ask me
as a standard but at least in freshly
operated
animals do use these techniques it's
really there's really no need to
pick up a freshly operated mouse by the
tail
if not needed tunnel cup handling really
makes it easier for you
and for the animals
and then my last
slide today i don't think there is a
good
pain treatment protocol without a good
pain assessment protocol
the experience of the same procedure may
differ in different individuals
um you might differ in your performance
of the procedure
therefore one it might be pain more
painful
one time than the other time and the
drug treatment might fail or might
differ
and every time there might be unexpected
pain that could occur
so use these if you have these very
specific
pain signs maybe for abdominal pain use
them
if you maybe you want to use
a more general one one like the most
criminal scale
that's useful sometimes it can be useful
to
observe also natural behaviors
like now spelling or social behavior or
boring behavior
and with this i'm going to sum up well
analgesia
and pain assessment is an ethical and
scientific
must they are very good reasons to take
care of these
it's not that trivial all the time
sometimes
it can be quite tricky especially if you
want to
adjust that to a very specific
experimental
setup or readout and therefore
why not try to get the help of an expert
in veterinary analgesia
to my knowledge most of these experts i
have
met at least those that i have met are
quite nice people so i think they will
be
very happy to help you um keep in mind
there is no gold standard
you need to estimate the expected pain
in your
individual patient i then you can choose
an adequate analgesic substance
ideally this shouldn't be mono analgesia
but multimodal
analgesia
try to refine your administration
protocol
it should still be secure but if you can
use a less stressful protocol then go
for it
um and whenever possible apply
non-pharmalogical
measures that can be a refinement
and then assess the efficiency of your
protocol
and then start again right if you see
something is wrong you have to start
again
and change your protocol maybe okay with
this
um i'm finished
if you have any questions left if
something is unclear
feel free to drop me an email or use the
question
on some books here in this system
yeah i hope you enjoyed bye